à la Une fustine les amboisiens n'ont pu
profiter qu'un mois et demi du nouveau
centre aquatique avant qu'il ne soit
fermé il avait ouvert en octobre mais
déjà l'ARS a pris la décision de fermer
la piscine à cause de la présence d'une
bactérie dans le bassin elle n'est pas
très dangereuse mais le seuil de
tolérance a été dépassé de 10 % pour
l'instant pas de date certaine pour la
réouverture il faut attendre les
résultats de nouveaux tests alors
comment cette bactérie a-t-elle pu
proliférer explication de léat
Turquie
16h un mercredi après-midi et des
bassins bien vides à peine 2 mois après
son ouverture le centre aquatique du Val
d'embboise ferme momentanément ses
portes la cause un taux de bactérie
supérieur à la norme détecté dans les
bassins des analyses ont été faites
vendredi dernier comme on en fait très
régulièrement et ces analyses ont montré
que on avait un un taux de bactérie sur
une bactérie particulière un peu trop
élevé par rapport à la norme on s'est
beaucoup renseigné on a appelé des
services médicaux on a discuté avec la
l'agence régionale de santé et il
s'avère que c'est un très classique dans
un centre aquatique que ce type de
bactéries monte sensiblement le centre
presque victime de son succès attire les
foules une fréquentation triplée les
weekends par rapport à l'ancienne
piscine de la commune ce qui multiplie
fatalement les chances de propagation de
bactéries d'autant plus qu'ici il n'y a
pas de chlore à la place l'eau est
filtré à plusieurs reprises puis
désinfecté pour éliminer les impuretés
une méthode innovante qui oblige à une
plus grande vigilance quant à la qualité
de l'eau il faut savoir que par exemple
sur notre ancienne piscine en bois qui
était traité au chlore l' RS venait une
fois par trimestre et là sur notre
traitement biominéral ils viennent une
fois tous les 15 jours c'est les filtres
qui vont qui bossent il tournent à fond
on les met en marche forcé plusieurs
fois par jour de manière à ce qu'on
vraiment on filtre bien très fortement
l'eau très régulièrement et puis elle va
partir toute seule l'agence régionale de
santé centre Val-de Loire devrait
procéder à de nouvelles analyses vendi
si les taux sont de retour à la normale
le centre rouvrira donc ses portes au
public dès le début de la semaine
prochaine